[Music]
sexuality and power are tightly
interwoven and this is not the first
time that people take on the abuses of
power that are inflicted upon people
through the currency of sex Anita Hill
not that long ago took on Clarence
Thomas but maybe what changed is not so
much the accused as well as the accuser
that perhaps women today have enough
massa and enough power themselves to
withstand the forces of denial and so
the system for the first time has to
reckon and has to act with consequence
to the allegations that are being made
the big question is not why is that is
there anything more happening today is
that people have not spoken out women
children lots of people who often were
disempowered and humiliated did not
speak out because of the fear that it
would not be believed this is what is
changing is that the burden of proof is
switching a little bit and a certain
norm is shifting one of the very good
examples for me when I look at shifting
norms is corporal punishment for a long
time parents teachers could hit their
children it was part of discipline and
part of child-rearing a norm shifted
that said this is no longer possible
this is actually not a means for
education this is not a decent pedagogy
this is harmful and this is violent
similarly something is shifting in the
conduct between men and women it's a
given that power and sex are intertwined
but sometimes they are intertwined in a
way where it becomes power too and
therefore there is a power to feel
affirmed to feel desire to feel strong
etc versus a power over and that is a
form of humiliation of oppression in
which it is very little about sex and a
lot more about violence so I think first
of all we need to were using the word
miss condom
and we are lumping in that word a number
of different behaviors we are talking
about harassment we are talking about
assault we are talking about rape these
that very different experiences degrees
of experiences first of all second I
think that before we only focus on
misconduct we need to talk about male
sexuality male sexual conduct rather
than only the misconduct there needs to
be a context to this so it is true that
in a different context women of a
certain generation accepted a certain
kind of banter or a certain kind of
conversation vocabulary sexual ization
use of power that they themselves
participated in as well that was that
allowed women to actually be told all
kinds of things for which they would
have had probably different reactions
than the younger generation today it
just was part of the deal that's what
you have to contend with and you know
that some of them are vulgar and some of
them have utter poor taste
and some of them are creepy and you just
manage it you manage a culture like that
I think what is shifting is people are
no longer willing to manage it to take
this as the granted norm and then hope
that under on the periphery of that
there are other kinds of behavior I
think what is shifting is that the
periphery is coming to the center and a
whole context the whole ecology that was
seemingly accepted or tolerated is no
longer tolerated and those shifts take
place culturally all the time where we
put the boundaries what we consider is
transgressive what we can see you know
there is a difference women have known
the difference between receiving a
compliment and being degraded in one
they feel enhanced they feel beautiful
they feel appreciated they feel
recognized for the efforts that they
have put into making themselves look
good in the other they feel itchy
they feel dirty they feel spoiled they
it they know the difference it's it's a
visceral difference and then they may be
arranged their way sometimes they're not
sure but that is a small part of not
being sure with major territories of
clear delineation between desire between
a compliment and between degradation in
the last weeks I have actually conducted
a number of large-scale conversations
about sex and power men and women where
we go from here and I think that what
needs to happen is a place where men can
speak about their confusions where men
can speak about their vulnerability
safely where men can speak about their
their their their self doubts at times
about really knowing what does woman
want the way that Freud asked the
question in the century ago and in in a
space where women can safely speak and
be angry the shift is for men to have a
safe space to be vulnerable and for
women to have a safe space to express
their aggression the safe space to
express their anger their resentment
over the amount of acceptances of
microaggressions that they have had to
deal with and at this point a roar is
coming out of them it's no longer okay
but to only create a legal environment
in which people just go after the other
and punish them and reinforce more
distrust I'm not sure that that's the
society we want to live in we want a
society in which people can Intuit each
other better in which people are able to
experience the ambiguities of iterations
and reiterations that are part of all
relational systems we don't want to have
women not be hired because why are
suspicious of them and in which women
and men are constantly afraid of each
other suspicious of each other and and
and looking out for the way that each of
them is going to take advantage of the
other or is going to lash out at the
other we do want a place in which we
play a culture in which
there is a greater sense of
understanding a greater sense of empathy
in which men understand the experience
of women and in which women understand
the experience of men and that requires
an enormous amount of contact and
communication and from very young on
from little children on that requires a
culture that does not from the beginning
create pink and blue with with the sense
in which know that none of these two can
ever understand each other and my work
is about creating those conversations
those dialogues those places in which
men hear women in a way they've never
listened to them and where women hear
men speak about their experience in a
way that men have never even uttered
neither to other men for that matter you
know and it is that socialization
process that I take on in my work around
gender gender socialization and the
larger culture of men and women and the
fluidity in-between
[Music]
you